it's great to be joined today by Carl
Zimmer who's a columnist for The New
York Times also author most recently if
she has her mother's laugh the power
perversions and potential of heredity
Carl it's so great to talk to you you
know we've been following the
development of genetic editing
technology CRISPR we've had medical
ethicists on the program to discuss the
issue I guess to kind of get us started
in this conversation has the discussion
around genetic editing in humans changed
fundamentally over the last five 10 or
15 years as a result of the technology
that has advanced or is the debate and
controversy around it basically the same
one that's been around for a couple of
decades I think that the debate is
getting more realistic in the sense that
that people are actually able to point
to particular kinds of technologies and
say you know we could actually use this
and make particular changes to - to the
human genome before a lot of it was
quite hypothetical almost science
fiction but now you know there are
experiments going on where scientists
appear to being able to make precise
changes to you human embryos that they
can do it so so the debate has gotten
more realistic it's also gotten more
urgent because this is going to happen
quickly one of the I guess I'd call it
an argument or talking points that you
will often read in opposition to this
type of technology is that it's going to
lead to rich people being able to afford
designer babies it could lead to even a
larger gap in terms of wealth and and
income over the long term because you're
going to have rich people who are going
to be able to etc etc I think you
understand the argument is that the
actual concern that should be debated or
is that sort of a false debate in your
mind um I think that it's not really
getting at the heart of the technology
in terms of a debate you know
that is really
a question about how we hand out medical
services really you know I mean what if
we lived in a country where anybody
could use CRISPR on their child you know
safe through some kind of socialized
medicine system suddenly that debate
goes away but you know I don't think
that people would say oh okay it's all
settled then
you know I think there are more
fundamental issues about CRISPR that
really feel you know deeply
uncomfortable to a lot of people just
the mere fact of being able to change
the future of heredity and you know we
should explore that why why is that so
unsettling to us and our are we right to
feel that way or maybe we should just
learn to like it one of the primary ways
that arthur caplan sort of said or
suggested that we should divide genetic
edits into categories was the type that
would persist to the children of those
who have had the modifications done and
those that would not in other words
those that would not be passed along in
your mind is that a reasonable way to
sort of categorize the types of edits
that could conceivably be done I think
that's a good first pass you know
because I mean the fact is that
scientists been developing ways to treat
genetic disorders for decades and we're
really on the verge of starting to have
really effective treatments that
actually change the genes themselves but
we're talking here about you know a
person who is born with a disease and
then at some point later they get a
treatment so maybe in the future people
could get say a treatment for hemophilia
where you either insert a working copy
of the of that blood clotting gene and
to their cells or maybe you go in with
gene editing technology like CRISPR and
you change it but they won't pass that
down on the next generation if you
change the embryo and fix that
that change then you are talking about
things they're going to be inherited in
the next generation and so if there's
any issue concerns about safety it's not
just that one patient you're thinking
about you have to think about the person
who inherits those genes from from that
patient one of the things I think about
in in this discussion but really in any
discussion about technology is that the
argument that the technology could be
misused or used in ways that would not
be in line to maybe maximize well-being
or whatever standard you want to apply
to it that type of argument has sort of
also been around right I mean if you go
back to like a crude example where where
the automobile became something that was
clearly on the horizon there was the
argument made that it would have this
bad side effect of the horse buggy
drivers are going to lose their job and
obviously when we get more distance from
that a fork in the road so to speak we
realize it was silly to ever think that
that was going to be an argument to hold
back the development of the car are you
swayed in general by arguments about how
a technology could be misused or is that
just inherent to anything that humans
develop you know it's interesting and
talk about the car I mean we we kind of
we do laugh about you know the the
plight of the horse buggy whip maker you
know and and and that seems kind of
laughable you know on the other hand
cars have been a major source of
pollution that has you know cut a lot of
life short honestly with particulate
matter and our major emitters of
greenhouse gases and those were things
that I don't think really anybody really
thought about initially and until and
then it only really became clear after
that technology was really locked in I
mean we depend on cars you know and and
unless you're Amish should going back to
a carriage isn't really an option so
they're I think they're always going to
be you know these are unknown unknowns
when it comes to technology and I think
we just that we have to be mindful of
that and we have to be sort of
monitoring these things as we go along I
don't think that we should stop you know
exploration of Technology
you know vaccines antibiotics and so on
I mean all these things have helped to
make the world a much better place but
on the other hand you know we have to
bear in mind that there might be
something wrong with something we're
inventing now that we may not realize
till much later and when you're talking
about oh you know the human gene pool
that's that's pretty serious stuff yeah
I mean I guess if there's a lesson to be
taken from the the horse buggy car
example it's that we likely won't know
that the real challenge is to contend
with until much later the ones that we
think are going to be the main ones end
up actually not being the primary
concerns yeah and and you know it it
doesn't help in this regard that you
know we humans live a pretty long time
and so you know what if there are you
know what if there are issues with
CRISPR and heredity that don't really
show up until the next generation or the
generation after that you know are you
gonna wait 40 50 80 years to really get
a clear sense of how safe things are
it's it's particularly tricky for humans
but then again like we can't we can't
just say well we can't do any medical
research for fear that something bad
might happen there is a connection
between CRISPR and genetically modified
foods which is something we've talked
about on the program for a long time
I've interviewed George church here here
in Boston at Harvard University about
about the topic I have sort of catalyzed
some anger from many in my audience a
predominantly progressive left-wing
audience because I've taken the position
which I believe is based in science that
there is no evidence that genetically
modified foods are harmful to human
health on the basis merely of their
genetic modification that if you combine
GMOs with harmful pesticides then yes
those GMOs could be damaging to human
health but because of the pesticides not
because of their genetically modified
nature in and of itself this is
something that's connected to the work
that you've done do you have a strong
position generally on the safety of
genetically modified foods specifically
on the basis of there be
genetically modified well I think that
it's important to bear in mind that
every time you somebody produces a new
batch of C's there are some new
mutations in them and that you know the
whole history of domestication has
involved you taking advantage of
mutations and favoring some over others
and combining them through breeding and
so on now that being said you know
nobody ever crossed a corn stock with a
strawberry so you know there are
certainly are limits to that kind of
that kind of breeding but on the other
hand you know if you're concerned about
taking genes from one species and
putting them into another then CRISPR is
the solution to your problems really
because because CRISPR is basically you
snipping out small pieces of DNA or
changing you know like a single letter
to to new one in in the DNA it's it's
not putting in these these huge changes
and so and in fact it and you know in
terms of like new mutations that may
arise by by accident with this process
it's no more than what you'd get through
regular breeding the one one element of
this debate that I see come up time and
again is that you will see some
detractors of GMO foods say things like
we don't know if it's safe because it
hasn't been studied because big
agriculture doesn't allow it to be
studied in my research that seems to be
patently untrue in other words that
while while big agriculture may not be
funding those studies or at least the
unbiased studies that we would hope to
see that the academic world has actually
been studying GMO food for a long time
and there there are there seem to be
countless studies about it oh sure
of course I mean go go to Cornell
University go to University of Minnesota
go to University of california-davis
you'll find tons of research on us I
mean in my book she hasn't
laughs I went to Cold Spring Harbor
Laboratory and spent time with a
scientist there who is using CRISPR to
try to produce tomatoes that can grow
further north and because of by
extending their growing season and it's
all he is doing is he's snipping out
small chunks of DNA that that are
involved in controlling when they flower
so you know yeah I mean it's it's it's
it's not something that is be CRISPR
it's not something that's being hidden
in some corporate lab now I but I don't
want to make it sound like everything is
totally perfect in advance you know I
mean it we do have an issue right now
with with with herbicides as you
mentioned I mean the either one of the
main herbicides that is being used with
these GM crops is starting to become
useless because evolution has basically
bred resistant weeds that happened
before with regular pesticides and
regular crops now it's happening again
and so now some of the big companies are
moving to another herbicide that died
camba which is a lot of people have a
lot of scientists have a lot of serious
concerns about the use of it so you know
the GMOs I don't see them as being some
kind of monster but they're certainly
not a panacea and if if GM crops mean
that we end up using some some
herbicides that are of serious health
concerns then that's not really a great
solution we've been speaking with Carl
Zimmer who's a columnist for the new
york times most recently author of she
has her mother's laughs the power
perversions and potential of heredity
which I highly recommend Carl really a
pleasure speaking with you today thanks
so much for having me take care